new show is based on a famous sci-fi
novel right yeah it's based on a book by
William Gibson who is kind of known as
like the Godfather of sci-fi in a lot of
ways
um it's really it's a really wonderful
show and it takes place around a young
girl named Flynn Fisher who's in a small
town in the Appalachian Mountains yeah
and basically she plays video games for
a living to be able to make money and
she uses other people's avatars and one
day she has the opportunity to beta test
a new headset
um from a very mysterious company and
she puts the headset on and she realizes
that she's not operating a game but
she's actually operating a robot body in
the future in the year 2100 in London
it's so interesting yeah yeah is this
why because this is your first TV kind
of thing right or like episodic thing
all right yeah that's my first TV yeah
pretty much ever yeah I love that you
chose this says like you love gaming
though too in real life right I do yeah
I do love game there's a lot of
parallels between my character and
myself in this show in a lot of ways and
gaming is a huge one I've been a big
gamer since I was really young I have
four brothers and like I couldn't
physically
but like I could always best them at
every turn in terms of gaming oh I love
it and I'm always better than them it is
so I was like hell yeah you know it's so
interesting I took flying lessons they
say sometimes oh I did because I was
terrified of it and I was trying to
overcome the fear it didn't work um but
anyway but it is it is it it's no I
didn't like it I don't like flying but I
but I did like the lesson of it but it
was funny because the the guy kept
saying my instructor kept Randy kept
saying women are actually usually better
at this because of how your minds work
yes and how you he's like I've just
taught so many men and women and they're
so I wonder if that correlates to like
gaming World 100 kind of computer
correlates I mean it's a very male
dominated sport on the outside is how
people look at it yeah but in actuality
yeah it is
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah they call it being sweaty so like
when so when like you're playing Call of
Duty and it's really hard they're like
wow this is like a sweaty this is a
sweaty game right now you play Call of
Duty yeah that's my game oh my God I've
seen someone play that game and I'm like
this is an intense game oh yeah yeah and
swimming okay so you've said that the
way you've been treated um as a woman in
the industry people are treated like
that in the game world too right for
sure so it is like it is a very like a
male dominated field I don't hear a lot
of females going and I'm a gamer I'm a
sport i Sport it out I I sport it out
online
um you know it's funny the the ratio of
men to women in in the sport is actually
really high like a lot of women game
yeah but we use male avatars because
there's kind of such an aggression
towards Women Within it that a lot of us
pretend to be guys which is what I've
done all the years that I play games wow
that sucks yeah and so now I think
there's a lot more communication going
on about it where people are really
talking about women getting into gaming
openly because our minds do work
differently than guys so we do have a
bit of a mental dexterity Edge that's
different than the way that a guy might
play a game and stuff like that yeah
yeah so for sure I love that I could get
into gaming because you sit there
[Music]
[Applause]